nun also erstmals eine Diskussion auch
hier im Parlament und zwar in einer
sogenannten orientierungsdebatte ganze
drei Stunden sind dafür vorgesehen jede
Partei hat eine Redezeit entsprechend
ihrem sitzverhältnis zur Verfügung die
SPD zum Beispiel 50 Minuten sie will
diese auf zwölf Redner verteilen damit
möglichst viele Meinungen heute gehört
werden das Plenum ist bereits voll
besetzt aber es läuft noch die vorherige
Debatte bis es losgeht schalten wir zu
meiner Kollegin Ines Trams die vor Ort
im Bundestag die Debatte beobachten wird
Ines was ist das Besondere heute an
dieser Debatte es hat eine solche
orientierungsdebatte ja schon öfter mal
gegeben zum Beispiel beim Thema
Sterbehilfe oder der Ehe für alle
ich denke heute kann man tatsächlich das
Wort
orientierungsdebatte im Wortsinn
verstehen wir haben uns hier in den
Fluren rund um den Plenarsaal umgehört
und ja es gibt natürlich Verfechter
einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht es gibt
strikte Gegner einer solchen Impfpflicht
aber auch ganz viele Abgeordnete die
noch unsicher sind die sich ein Bild
machen wollen die das kennt man auch
nicht von Abgeordneten so häufig das
erlebt man nicht so häufig die sagen ich
weiß noch nicht wo ich stehe ich möchte
mich orientieren ich möchte vielleicht
auch noch mit dem einen oder anderen
Experten sprechen also insofern diese
Ratlosigkeit denke ich die schwebt hier
heute über der ganzen Veranstaltung und
ja also insofern ist es eine besondere
Debatte die ja auch nicht entlang von
Parteigrenzen verlaufen wird spannend
wird das für uns und auch für unsere
Zuschauer
ja das hoffen wir natürlich die Union
wirft der Regierung ja vor keinen
Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen da sie wohl
keine Mehrheit dafür hätte für eine
Impfpflicht sondern dies dem Parlament
zu überlassen wie ist denn da gerade der
Stand welche Anträge gibt es denn
derzeit gibt es überhaupt welche
von der Union gibt es im Moment noch
keinen Antrag die Union hat in dieser
Sache eher schwammig Unentschieden
bislang agiert mit Blick auf das
Verfahren aber auch mit Blick auf die
eigene Meinung auf eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht wir hören es soll nun heute
nach der Debatte möchte die Union einen
eigenen Antrag vorstellen wie der
aussieht wissen wir noch nicht richtig
ist wir werden heute in der Debatte viel
von CDU und CSU hören an Vorwürfen
gerichtet an die ampelkoalitionäre der
Vorwurf ist ja die Ampel hätte sich
mehrheitlich für eine Impfpflicht
ausgesprochen und traut sich aber nun
nicht einen Antrag dafür vorzulegen weil
eben doch die Sorge besteht dass da die
FDP aus den Reihen der eigenen Koalition
querschießen könnte ja danke ihnen ist
erstmal da die Debatte noch nicht
begonnen hat nutzen wir die Zeit um
Ihnen ein Gespräch zu zeigen mit Dirk
Wiese von der SPD dass meine Kolle Ines
Trams vor etwa einer halben Stunde
geführt hat
ich begrüße Dirk Wiese von der
SPD-Fraktion und mit Unterzeichner des
Antrags für eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
ab 18 Jahren ein Antrag den die
Ampelkoalition vorgelegt hat Herr Wiese
im Moment wissen wir ja überhaupt nicht
was wird uns schützen vor einer
eventuellen neuen virus-variante wie oft
muss man geimpft werden wie lange hält
ein Impfschutz das sind ziemlich
unsichere Säulen auf die Sie Ihren
Antrag aufbauen
es sind Fragen die eine Antwort bedürfen
aber nach allen Meinungen und
Einschätzung von Expertinnen und
Experten schützen drei Impfungen
ausreichend vor einem schweren Verlauf
man hat dann eine gute
Grundimmunisierung eine weitere
boosterung im Herbst ist sicherlich dann
sinnvoll freiwillig auch für Menschen
mit Vorerkrankungen aber nochmal drei
Impfungen sind eine ausreichende
Grundimmunisierung gegen schwere
Verläufe das ist auch mit die Grundlage
unseres Antrags für eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ab 18 darüber werden wir
heute diskutieren und wird eine
spannende Debatte werden schon heute
erleben ungeimpfte in Deutschland viele
viele ein Erkrankungen meinen sie dass
ein Bußgeld eine Impfpflicht diese
impfskeptiker überzeugen kann ist da
nicht viel mehr ja Überzeugung anderer
Art notwendig auf der anderen Seite
erleben viele BundesbürgerInnen und
Bundesbürger Einschränkungen die geimpft
sind die geboostert sind die nicht zur
kulturellen Veranstaltungen gehen können
die nicht normal in Restaurants gehen
können die nicht zu Fußballspielen gehen
können wie sich das vorstellen und darum
ist auch hier die Frage zu stellen ob es
nicht sinnvoll ist diese Impfpflicht
einzuführen um endlich aus dieser
Pandemie herauszukommen dass wir in eine
beherrschbare Situation reinkommen dass
die Belastung des Gesundheitswesens
nicht uns alle paar Monate ereilt und
gerade auch vor dem Hintergrund halte
ich diesen grundrechtseinfluss Eingriffe
verhältnismäßig weil er andere
Grundrechtseingriffe nicht mehr
erforderlich macht und das ist eine
Abwägungsentscheidung die ich hier
getroffen habe für mich und darum bin
ich auch für die allgemeine Impfpflicht
dank ihnen Dirk Wiese er sagt nur mit
einer Impfpflicht kommen wir aus dem
Teufelskreislauf von Lockdown und
Lockerungen heraus
doch es gibt auch im Parlament natürlich
nicht nur Befürworter der Impfpflicht
der Riss geht durch alle Parteien bis
auf die AFD viele Parlamentarier sind
noch unentschieden auch mit einer
Gegnerin einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht
hat Ines Trams gesprochen mit Christine
Aschenberg dugnus von der FDP
an meiner Seite begrüße ich Christine
Aschenberg dugnes Gesundheitspolitikerin
der FDP-Fraktion und
mitunterzeichnerin des bislang einzigen
Antrags gegen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht Frau aschmeck-prognose wenn
man sagt impfen ist der Schlüssel zurück
zu einem normalen Leben und wenn man
erkennt dass alle anderen Maßnahmen die
letzten anderthalb zwei Jahre versagt
haben muss man dann nicht zu einer
Impfpflicht kommen denn zu wenig
deutsche sind geimpft ich gebe ihnen
insofern recht als ich sage
selbstverständlich müssen wir die
Impfbereitschaft erhöhen und das ist
auch Titel unseres Antrages wir wollen
die Impfbereitschaft in der Bevölkerung
erhöhen aber eben ohne eine Impfpflicht
und da sagt selbst der Ethikrat in
seinem Gutachten vom Dezember das noch
nicht alles getan wurde um eben
denjenigen zu erreichen die Angst vor
einer Impfung haben die Fragen haben die
zum Beispiel sagen ich weiß nicht ob ich
danach noch schwanger werden kann als
junge Frau diese Fragen müssen wir
beantworten und ich denke wir haben noch
nicht alles getan es ist ja ein schwerer
Grundrechtseingriff und da sagen auch
die Verfassungsrechtler alles was
niederschwelliger ist alles was geringer
ist als Eingriff müssen wir zuerst
einmal umgesetzt haben sie sprechen das
ist typisch FDP sie sprechen von einem
Eingriff einem zu starken Eingriff in
die Grundrechte was aber ist mit dem
Schutz des Allgemeinwohls mit dem Schutz
des Lebens anderer selbstverständlich
muss es immer eine Abwägung sein und
deswegen nehmen wir diese Debatte ja
auch sehr ernst und deswegen freue ich
mich auch über diese
orientierungsdebatte so es tut mir leid
dass ich das unterbrechen muss weil wir
sehen dass die Debatte beginnt wir gehen
rüber in den Plenarsaal eröffnen wird
die Debatte Dagmar Schmidt
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
und gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Fraktion die Fraktion haben sich
darauf geeinigt dass die Redner
entsprechend den Ressorts ausgesucht
werden es beginnen daher die
Gesundheitspolitiker
wir erleben täglich steigende
Infektionszahlen die Höchstwerte
erreichen viele Menschen sind erschöpft
und wir alle wünschen uns eine möglichst
schnelle Rückkehr zu einem normalen
Alltag
eine Impfpflicht wirft fachlich
schwierige und rechtlich rechtlich wie
ethisch Kontroverse Fragen auf
sie zwingt uns zu komplexen Abwägungen
heute tauschen wir uns darüber aus was
für eine allgemeine verpflichtende
Impfung spricht und was dagegen
wir hören Vorschläge Bedenken Einwände
und sortieren Optionen ergebnisoffen
über Fraktionsgrenzen hinweg
bedenken wir dabei dass die Menschen in
dieser angespannten Zeit von uns vor
allem Orientierung erwarten
deshalb wünsche ich mir eine faire
respektvolle und konstruktive Debatte
die parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführerinnen und Geschäftsführer
haben sich darauf verständigt dass es in
dieser Debatte keine Kurzintervention
und keine Zwischenfragen geben soll
alle Abgeordneten deren redewünsche
nicht berücksichtigt werden können haben
die Möglichkeit ihre Redebeiträge zu
Protokoll zu geben
sind Sie damit einverstanden
das ist der Fall dann verfahren wir so
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
180 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne hiermit die Aussprache das
Wort hat zu Beginn für die SPD-Fraktion
Dagmar Schmidt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin froh
und dankbar dass wir die Debatte zu
Impfpflicht heute hier führen hier im
Parlament wo diese Debatte hingehört und
ich bin mir sicher dass der
demokratische Teil dieses Hauses sie
trotz aller Unterschiede sehr angemessen
und respektvoll führen wird
man kann sich irgendetwas selber
ausdenken
zusammenschwurbeln dabei immer gegen die
da oben hetzen und den Leuten dummes
Zeug erzählen das ist einfach und nutzt
allen denjenigen die das Vertrauen in
unsere demokratischen und
wissenschaftlichen Institutionen
zerstören wollen man kann es sich aber
auch
wie die allermeisten die anstrengende
Mühe machen Verantwortung zu übernehmen
abzuwägen
zu diskutieren immer wieder auf die
neuesten wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse
zu reagieren zu versuchen kompliziertes
einfach zu machen auch wenn uns das
nicht immer gelingt dabei müssen wir die
Sorgen und Ängste auf der einen Seite
aber eben auch die Erwartung an
konsequentes Handeln auf der anderen
Seite sehr ernst nehmen und deswegen
sollte uns alle ein Anliegen einen
nämlich dass wir noch mal einen großen
Anlauf machen aufeinander zugehen und
zum Impfen einladen dass wir überzeugen
Sorgen ernst nehmen und Fragen
beantworten
denn es ist kein kleiner Schritt wenn
lange Zeit eine Impfpflicht
ausgeschlossen wurde und diese dann doch
eingeführt werden soll warum ich es
trotzdem für notwendig halte will ich
kurz erläutern den in Wirklichkeit reden
wir ja nicht über eine Impfpflicht ja
oder nein sondern wir reden über
Alternativen im Umgang mit der Pandemie
und jede Entscheidung auch die dagegen
hat Konsequenzen zu denen man sich dann
eben auch bekennen muss und welche
Alternativen haben wir erste Alternative
es laufen lassen das führt irgendwann zu
einer grundimmunität vorher führt es
aber zu vielen Toten Kranken und
longkowit-patienten es führt dazu dass
Menschen wegen Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems nicht mehr behandelt
werden können und zu unmenschlichen
Anforderungen an diejenigen die dort
arbeiten wir haben uns aus guten Gründen
bisher dagegen entschieden und auch
Omicron ändert daran nichts
die zweite Alternative um das Virus im
Griff zu halten kennen wir nur allzu gut
kontaktbeschränkungen
Zugangsbeschränkungen all die Maßnahmen
bis hin zum Lockdown
es droht also wieder ein Herbst und
Winter wie dieses und letztes Jahr nur
dass es jetzt wirklich an uns selber
liegt das zu ändern weil wir die Mittel
in der Hand halten und so komme ich zur
dritten alternative einer sehr hohen
Impfquote davon sind wir trotz aller
Bemühungen noch sehr weit entfernt und
deswegen brauchen wir für den Weg aus
der Pandemie eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
[Applaus]
die Impfstoffe die wir haben zählen mit
zu den besten überhaupt mit inzwischen
weltweit knapp fünf Milliarden geimpften
wissen wir das sehr gut nach dem Stand
der Wissenschaft bieten drei Impfungen
einen guten Schutz gegen schwere
Verläufe und Tod auch bei Varianten wir
kommen damit zu einer Grundimmunisierung
ähnlich wie bei der Grippe und viele
haben diese auch schon wir wollen alle
ab 18 einbeziehen damit alle mit allen
solidarisch sind die mit mehr Kontakten
mit denen die ein größeres Risiko haben
und umgekehrt
wir wollen
eine Auswahlmöglichkeit für die
Impfstoffe und Ausnahmen für die die
sich aus medizinischen auch psychischen
Gründen nicht impfen lassen können und
wir wollen bei der Durchsetzung eine
Balance halten zwischen ernsthafter
Durchsetzung mit Nachweispflicht und
Bußgeldern weil wir eben sonst das Ziel
nicht erreichen aber wir wollen dabei
die Verhältnismäßigkeit bewahren die
Impfpflicht ist ein milderes Mittel als
die Gefährdung der Gesundheit durch
durch solche und auch als weitere
Einschränkungen die vor allem Kinder und
Jugendliche aber viele andere mehr
Treffen mit harten Folgen psychischen
Folgen vergangenen Lebenschancen
finanziellen Problemen Zukunftsängsten
wir haben einen Weg aus der Pandemie der
heißt impfen damit wir wieder
damit wir wieder unbeschwert Freunde
sehen uns umarmen Kunst und Kultur
genießen feiern singen und tanzen können
ich freue mich drauf
eine Impfpflicht unter bestimmten
Voraussetzungen fordert Dagmar Schmidt
es sind wie gesagt heute zuerst die
Gesundheitspolitiker die hier reden
werden es folgt nun Tino Sorge der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der Union
nächster Redner der Abgeordnete
tino-sorge aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der Gesundheitsminister hat das sich ja
geweigert einen konkreten Vorschlag zu
unterbreiten und deshalb finde ich die
orientierungsdebatte auch vor dem
Hintergrund sehr interessant dass uns
vielleicht heute verraten wird wie sein
Antrag aus einem Vorschlag genau
aussehen könnte ich glaube 80 Millionen
Menschen interessiert das in Deutschland
auch und insofern möchte ich auch im
Vorfeld meiner Rede noch kurz darauf
hinweisen dass es wirklich schade ist
dass auch hier bei diesem Thema was wir
heute in einer orientierungsdebatte hier
diskutieren keinerlei
ich sage jetzt mal Richtung auch das
Bundeskanzlers oder auch das
Gesundheitsministers vorgegeben worden
das ist erinnert mich so ein bisschen an
Versteckspiel man spielt solange
verstecken und hofft dass irgendjemanden
Konzept so Impfpflicht vorlegt wenn man
nur lange genug darauf wartet und
deshalb meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
möchte ich auch noch mal in den Kontext
darauf hinweisen dass wir als Union
diese Debatte hier sehr begrüßen aber
wir hätten uns gewünscht dass wir diese
Debatte schon viel viel früher geführt
hätten nämlich vor Weihnachten als wir
einen langen Fragenkatalog an das
Bundeskanzleramt geschickt haben wo wir
im Vorfeld dieser Debatte gern einfach
mal gewusst hätten wie bestimmte Fragen
auch seitens der Bundesregierung
einsortiert werden denn die Fragen ja
muss man sagen sie sind gestern
beantwortet worden und auf die 22 22
wichtigsten Fragen wurden sage und
schreibe 12 Zeilen geantwortet also
insofern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kolleginnen frage ich wie ist das der
Anspruch der Bundesregierung ich hoffe
nein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Gesundheitskrise in der wir uns befinden
hat historische Ausmaße und deshalb ist
es ja auch so wichtig dass wir uns
überlegen wie können wir aus dieser
Pandemie herauskommen und deshalb ist es
im Rahmen dieser debat auch noch mal
ganz ganz wichtig voranzustellen dass
impfen der Weg aus der Pandemie ist und
insofern ist es ja deshalb auch so
wichtig dass wir uns darüber
verständigen wie denn eine Impfpflicht
aussehen könnte und nicht nur
plattitüten in den Raum stellen sagen
allgemeine Impfpflicht keine Impfpflicht
was auch immer sondern dass wir uns
darüber verständigen wie wir diese
Impfpflicht ausgestalten können und
deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen Sie uns auch die fachlichen
Bedenken ernster nehmen das hätten wir
uns gewünscht im Vorfeld der Debatte
dass wir auch Fragen eingehen wie kann
so eine Impfpflicht ausgestaltet werden
auch verfassungsrechtliche Fragen
spielen eine Rolle Juristen sagen uns
vor dem verfassungsrechtlichen
Hintergrund vor den Voraussetzungen ist
es eben doch nicht so einfach zu sagen
wir machen eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
ohne zu erklären wie denn diese
Impfpflicht aussehen könnte die
Mediziner bei uns impfenschutz bei
Corona wir wissen aber mittlerweile dass
die Impfstoffe nach einer gewissen Zeit
an Wirksamkeit verlieren das sind alles
Punkte die wir diskutieren hätten müssen
bereits im Vorfeld das sind alles Punkte
die uns die Bürger jeden Tag Fragen und
niemand gerade bei den Bürgern hat Lust
sich alle drei Monate oder alle vier
Monate Boostern lassen Boostern ohne
Ende kann nicht die Option sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und deshalb
möchte ich auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass die pauschalen Lösung
fast immer die schlechtesten Lösung sind
und deshalb sollten wir auch in der
Debatte differenzieren es muss doch
gerade darum gehen neben der Frage des
ob einer Impfpflicht auch zu diskutieren
wie denn diese Impfpflicht aussehen
könnte und das sollten wir genauer
hinschauen wie könnte das denn passieren
da hätte ich mir gewünscht dass der
Bundesgesundheitsminister nicht nur in
Talkshows eine Meinung äußert und sagt
allgemeine Impfpflicht sondern dass er
auch mal sagt wie stellt er sich das
denn vor geht es dabei um konkrete
Gruppen wie ist das Risiko zu bewerten
einzelner Risikogruppen wie ist die
Variante Omicron vor dem Hintergrund
Hospitalisierung zu bewerten zeitliche
Komponenten und noch mal wir brauchen
ein ordentliche Datengrundlage
deshalb liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen Sie uns doch auch in der Debatte
darüber sprechen wie wir diese
Datengrundlage verbreitern können also
ist dafür beispielsweise ein
impfregister der richtige Weg das ist
ein wichtiger Punkt über den wir
sprechen müssen bei der Frage wie wir
die Datengrundlage verbessern können
müssen wir auch darüber sprechen wie
diese feinen nyoncierungen Abstimmung im
Rahmen der Impfpflicht ausgestaltet
werden können und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen sie uns nicht immer nur
alles schlecht reden denn zu dieser
Debatte gehört auch die positiven Dinge
anzusprechen wir tun ja immer so als
hätten wir im Rahmen der Debatte
insbesondere auch im Hinblick auf eine
Impfpflicht überhaupt nichts geschafft
und wenn wir auf die Zahlen schauen 84
Prozent der Erwachsenen sind
mittlerweile vollständig geimpft 90
Prozent der Senioren sind mittlerweile
geimpft und das sollten wir nicht
kleinreden aber wir sollten auch immer
darauf hinweisen dass impfen der Weg aus
der Krise ist und zum Thema
Datengrundlage liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Fallzahlen und krankenhausinent sind als
Indikatoren gut sie müssen aber durch
weitere Parameter ergänzt werden wir
brauchen einen fortlaufenden Überblick
über die Auslastung der
normalstationären Kapazitäten digital
regional differenziert dass die die
Register beispielsweise könnte da ein
gutes Vorbild sein wir müssen aber auch
präzise erfassen wo Arztpraxen an
Belastungsgrenzen geraten und genauso
wichtig ist der Überblick über die
Funktionsfähigkeit kritischer
Infrastruktur deshalb liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir brauchen ein präziseres
Lagebild wir brauchen aber auch in der
Debatte mehr oder weniger Aufgeregtheit
wir müssen in der Debatte immer genau
begründen warum die Notwendigkeit in
einzelnen Bereichen für eine Impfpflicht
besteht denn Omegon das sage ich wie
viele andere auch ist zwar eine
dominante aber auch eine mildere
Variante und deshalb werden wir glaube
ich im Frühjahr einiges Althergebrachtes
überdenken müssen müssen und bei der
Frage ob wir dafür pauschale lö
Lösungen in den Blick nehmen eher auf
differenziertere setzen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nach zwei Jahren Pandemie und
erheblichen grundrechtseingriffen denke
ich sollten wir auch hier im Parlament
im Rahmen der Debatte uns gegenseitig
zugestehen dass bei den Meinungen ein
breites Meinungsspektrum insbesondere im
Hinblick auf die impflischpflicht
herrscht ich hätte mir deshalb gewünscht
dass wir bei der Frage wie wir diese
Debatte führen im Vorfeld zumindest ein
Entwurf gehabt hätten den man im
parlamentarischen Verfahren hätte
diskutieren können
das ist das ist leider nicht passiert
jetzt kann man sagen das ist vergossene
Milch mein persönlicher Wunsch ist
allerdings dass wir auch bei diesen
ganzen Debatten dass unsere
Koordinatensystem nicht verloren geht
dafür was der Staat tun sollte und was
nicht auch das Prinzip der
Eigenverantwortung der Bürger
Zurückhaltung des Staates sollten wir
nicht vergessen und insofern glaube ich
werden wir letztendlich bei der Frage
der Kompromissfindung hier im Parlament
wie üblich auch einen Kompromiss finden
noch mal das beste Instrument aus der
Pandemie herauszukommen ist das Impfen
aber solange kein Instrument mit
absolutem Schutz zur Verfügung steht
wäre auch eine absolute Impfpflicht der
falsche Weg das dennoch geht es darum
dass wir als Union einen pragmatischen
Ansatz finden differenzieren statt
Aktionismus Pragmatismus statt Panik das
ist für die Akzeptanz unverzichtbar denn
eine Impfpflicht die wir vor Ort
umsetzen müssen und wollen wird nur dann
akzeptiert wenn Sie auch tatsächlich
umgesetzt und nachvollziehbar ist und
nicht zuletzt wir in der politischen
Kultur und in der gesellschaftlichen
Debatte die Tür zur Versöhnung offen
halten lassen wir uns das nicht
vergessen vielen Dank
da warten die Kritik der Union an der
Regierung dass sie keinen Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt habe für Tino Sorge sind nach
wie vor zu viele Fragen offen zum
Beispiel wie eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
durchgeführt werden soll nächste
Rednerin ist Dr Kirsten Kappert Günther
von den Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Pandemie
setzt uns alle unter Druck Einsamkeit
seelische Belastungen nehmen zu Kinder
wollen endlich wieder unbeschwert lernen
und ihre Freundinnen treffen Künstlerin
warten darauf wieder aufzutreten und die
Menschen die Tag und Nacht unsere
Gesundheitsversorgung aufrecht erhalten
wollen endlich mal wieder Pause machen
uns eint liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dass wir diese Pandemie endlich
überwinden wollen und impfen ist der Weg
aus der Pandemie impfen ist der
Schlüssel dafür die Überlastung gesund
des Gesundheitssystems zu vermeiden
damit alle die medizinische und
pflegerische Hilfe brauchen Sie sicher
bekommen und dafür dafür brauchen wir
eine deutliche höhere Impfquote wir
liegen im europäischen Vergleich gerade
mal im Mittelfeld wäre die Impfkampagne
motivierender aufsuchender gewesen wie
im schönen Bundesland Bremen dann
müssten wir diese Debatte möglicherweise
gar nicht führen jetzt aber stehen wir
in der Verantwortung die bestehenden
Impflücken zu schließen
ich halte darum die Einführung einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht ab 18 für
richtig
sich impfen lassen zu können ist
übrigens ein Privileg wer kann sollte es
auch tun der Bundesverband der
Organtransplantierten unterstützt die
Impfpflicht ab 18 auch sie sind auf
unsere Solidarität angewiesen
eine Impfpflicht bedeutet eine doppelte
Verpflichtung eine Verpflichtung der
BürgerInnen sich impfen zu lassen und
eine Verpflichtung des Staats jeder
Person ein geeignetes impfangebot zur
Verfügung zu stellen so gehen in Pflicht
und impfrecht Hand in Hand
und wenn die Impfpflicht gelingen soll
dann heißt es nicht etwa weniger
Kommunikation sondern mehr
zielgruppenspezifische Aufklärung
mehrsprachig klar und verlässlich es
geht auch unter den Bedingungen einer
Impfpflicht immer um einen
ermöglichenden Staat das heißt für
Menschen die besondere Sorge haben wegen
der Spritze wegen der Impfung braucht es
über die ärztliche Aufklärung
hinausgehende Gesprächsangebote
macht es nun Sinn eine Impfpflicht auf
die über 50-Jährigen zu begrenzen ich
meine nein auch bei jüngeren Menschen
gibt es schwere Verläufe
longkowith ist ein zusätzliches Risiko
eine durchgemachte Infektion birgt nicht
nur für alle Altersgruppen hohe Risiken
sie schützt auch nicht so effektiv vor
weiteren Infektionen wie eine Impfung
und und das finde ich besonders relevant
wenn wir das Signal setzen würden impfen
ist vor allem für die über 50-Jährigen
wichtig birgt das sogar die Gefahr dass
die Impfbereitschaft bei den Jüngeren
abnimmt und das wäre kontraproduktiv
es gibt die Befürchtung dass eine
Impfpflicht zu mehr gesellschaftlicher
Spaltung führe ich gehe eher davon aus
dass eine klare und eindeutige
staatliche Regel die für alle
gleichermaßen gilt dabei hilft eine
gesellschaftliche Befriedung
herbeizuführen denn sie hilft auch
innere Ambivalenzen zu überwinden und
diese Chance sollten wir nutzen
je mehr Menschen in persönlichen Umfeld
geimpft sind desto höher ist auch die
eigene Impfbereitschaft es muss die
Regel werden geimpft zu sein und das
erreichen wir durch eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht lassen Sie uns gemeinsam
weiter im Austausch bleiben ich freue
mich auf die weiteren Beratungen vielen
Dank
das war Kirsten kopert-gonter von den
Grünen die übrigens selber Ärztin ist
mit einem eindeutigen Plädoyer für die
allgemeine Impfpflicht ab 18 nächster
Redner ist nun Tino propalla
co-vorsitzender der afd-fraktion die ja
eine Impfpflicht geschlossen ablehnt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Landsleute das Wetter der letzten Tage
ist der heutigen Debatte zur Impfpflicht
eigentlich angemessen es ist düster
bestellt um unser Land
als Abgeordnete dieses Hohen Hauses
setzen wir uns seit nunmehr als zwei
Jahren mit immer neuen Einschränkungen
und Verboten auseinander Werte Kollegen
wir alle erleben eine Zeit in der eine
deutsche Regierung wieder versucht ihre
autoritären Bestrebungen durch das
Parlament zu bringen die programmierte
Einigkeit der Koalitionäre ist medial
gestützt über Differenzen wird kaum oder
überhaupt nicht mehr diskutiert es wird
viel mehr nur noch diffamiert es drängt
sich mir förmlich das Bild einer
Bundesregierung auf die sich wie ein
verwundetes Tier schon fast ängstlich
zurückzieht und aggressiv um sich beißt
sobald sich jemand versucht ihr
argumentativ zu nähern im Ergebnis gibt
es nur noch ein richtig oder falsch es
wird durchregiert doch mit welchen
Folgen muss man sich fragen wir sind an
einem Punkt angelangt an dem Impfstoffe
schon fast eine religiöse Stellung
erhalten sie sollen das verbindende
Element für alle Bürger sein damit sie
einen Teil der Gesellschaft sein dürfen
wenn ich glaubt und von seinem
Grundrecht auf Selbstbestimmung Gebrauch
macht ist automatisch ausgeschlossen
beispiele hierfür erleben Sie alle
tagtäglich liebe Kollegen
einmalig jedoch ist das erstmals
Parlamentarier ihre Aufgaben nicht mehr
uneingeschränkt wahrnehmen können zwei
Beispiele kurz angeführt aus meiner
Fraktion wurde dem Kollegen Joachim
Wunder die Teilnahme an einer
Ausschusssitzung verwehrt
eine weitaus größere tragwerte werden
wir allerdings morgen erleben erstmals
erstmals werden nicht alle Mitglieder
des Deutschen Bundestages an der
Gedenkveranstaltung des 27 Januar
teilnehmen dürfen und der Grund in
beiden Fällen ein falscher sogenannter
fehlender Status die Begründung sind
vielfältig jedoch weder politisch
rechtlich noch medizinisch
nachvollziehbar und ich wiederhole das
noch mal eindrücklich ein nicht
geimpfter Parlamentarier gesund
getestet darf morgen nicht im Bundestag
betreten und vielmehr ist genau das und
ich zitiere Armin Laschet von gestern
Abend genau das ist eine Schande was
hier passiert
nicht die Kandidatur für das Amt des
Bundespräsidenten gilt es zu verurteilen
sondern die Art mit der die Regierenden
versuchen ihren Willen durchzusetzen und
die Arroganz diesen nicht einmal mehr
zur Diskussion zu stellen der Umgang mit
unserem Grundgesetz wird immer
schamloser nachträglich wird der Status
genesen durch eine staatliche
Institution aberkannt Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister brauchen wir
eigentlich ihr Ministerium noch oder
übernimmt das zukünftig komplett das RKI
falls ja da können wir die freien Mittel
in meine sächsische Heimatregion
investieren durch ihre vorzeitige
Energiewende samt der Industrialisierung
können wir dort jeden Euro dringend
gebrauchen meine Damen und Herren
diese politischen Schachzüge sind im
höchsten Maß zu verurteilen unsere
etablierten Strukturen werden ebenso
nachhaltig Gespräch geschwächt wie die
Stellung des Parlaments und genau das
ist die Demokratie gefährdet von der sie
ja sonst immer so gerne reden wer der
Bundesregierung geht es ihnen eigentlich
noch um unser Land oder um dem bloßen
Beweis wer eigentlich die Machthaber
sind und gegen
und gegen einige die mit der Moralkeule
durch unser Gesellschaft gehen wird nun
auch wegen Untreue ermittelt dass ein
schwerwiegender Tatbestand meine Damen
und Herren und viel schlimmer Frau
Berber und Herr Habig sie sind
Bundesminister ihres Kabinetts herr
Scholz wie glaubwürdig meinen sie
eigentlich sind diese Personalien für
unsere Bürger überhaupt noch
sie sind ganz offensichtlich einen
schwarz-weiß Denk- und Handlungsschema
über viele politikwälder hinweggefangen
sie haben vollkommen den Blick für ihre
eigentliche Aufgabe verloren eine Vision
für die Zukunft
eine Vision für die Zukunft unseres
Landes zu erzeugen die gibt es
schlichtweg nicht wir möchten Sie dass
Deutschland in 30 oder 70 Jahren
aussieht wie sieht eigentlich überhaupt
ihre
corona-exit-strategie aus sie ist
schlichtweg nicht vorhanden herr Scholz
alles Szenarien die Sie unseren Bürgern
skizzieren zeigen dass wir mit immer
mehr Einschränkungen leben lernen müssen
das ganze mit erneuerbaren Energien
einen immer stärker werdenden Staat und
voll digitalisiert natürlich wie man
davon jedoch seine Miete bezahlen soll
oder die Stromrechnung bezahlen soll
daran hat niemand gedacht dass ihnen
auch scheinbar völlig egal welche
Bundesregierung
geben Sie den Bürgern endlich Antworten
zu den Wirkungen und auch Nebenwirkungen
der Impfung deren Wirksamkeit und
Sicherheit werfen viele Fragen auf
schaffen sie endlich ein verlässliches
und vor allem vertrauensvolles Klima
eine Impfpflicht jedenfalls lehnen wir
sowohl für einzelne Berufsgruppen als
auch allgemein vollständig ab
die Alternative für Deutschland steht
für Freiheit statt Spaltung vielen Dank
das war Tino krupala von der AFD nach
wie vor sind viele Mitglieder der
afd-fraktion nicht geimpft heftige
Proteste deswegen gegen die geltenden
Regeln nicht nur im Bundestag nächster
Redner ist nun Justizminister Marco
Buschmann von der FDP
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gestatten Sie
mir eine Bemerkung vorneweg
wenn man merken wollte dass die AFD zur
Sache nichts beizutragen hat dann hat
man das jetzt gesehen weil außer wüste
Beschimpfung zu allen möglichen Dingen
und das Fehlen zu sachlichen Argumenten
zu der Debatte heute hat ihre Rede
nichts anderes gezeigt der Europa das
war glaube ich ein Schuss in den Ofen
wer möchte zweitens mich bedanken ich
möchte mich bei denen als Abgeordneter
bei den Fraktionen bedanken dass Sie
dieses debattenformat hier möglich
gemacht haben denn es ist der Sache
angemessen es ist auch dem Parlament
angemessen denn wir merken ja überall in
den Freundeskreisen auch in den
Ortsvereinen der Parteien in den Milieus
in den Vereinen überall wird über diese
Sache auch sehr leidenschaftlich zum
Teil auch sehr hitzig debattiert und da
gelten auch manch alte Regeln nicht und
deshalb ist es richtig und gut dass
dieses Verfahren dafür sorgt dass jede
Kollegin und jeder Kollege absolut frei
von allen Sorgen seine Bedenken seine
Argumente hier vortragen kann und das
zeigt dass das Gegenteil von dem
richtiges heropaler was sie behauptet
haben es gilt eben nicht die Logik der
Macht sondern es gilt die Logik des
Arguments und des Freigesprochenen
Wortes liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wer aus einer schwierigen Frage der
Ethik eine parteitaktische Frage der
Macht machen möchte beweist dass er oder
sie die Dimension der Frage nicht
verstanden hat
ich möchte ein paar Anmerkungen aus
rechtlicher Sicht machen wohlgemerkt
nicht in amtliche Eigenschaft sondern
weil ich das Recht zu meinem Beruf
gemacht habe und seit ich hier im
Parlament tätig bin auch immer mich um
Fragen des Rechts gekümmert habe und ich
höre immer wieder wenn es um die Frage
der Impfpflicht gehe dass da könne das
Verfassungsrecht in Wahrheit keinen
Beitrag zu leisten denn Karlsruhe habe
doch dem Gesetzgeber eine kart-lounge
gegeben und diese Missverständnis möchte
ich hier entgegentreten was Karlsruhe in
der
bundesnotbremsen Entscheidung gesagt hat
war dass diese Frage so komplex so
schwierig auch mit so vielen
prognostischen Elementen also
letztendlich Spekulationen auf die
Zukunft versehen ist das Richter ihre
Beurteilung nicht an die Stelle des
Gesetzgebers setzen können das heißt
aber nicht dass wir frei sind sondern
dass wir umso sorgfältiger über diese
sogar geringen müssen weil nach uns
keine andere Instanz in der Frage im
Ergebnis vermutlich mehr kommen wird und
auch deshalb ist dieses Verfahren der
Sache angemessen meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und der Beitrag des Verfassungsrechts zu
dieser Debatte ist neben den
medizinischen und ethischen Fragen enorm
denn unsere Verfassung verlangt von uns
dass wir das Ziel klar benennen da
reicht es nicht von einer Botschaft an
die geimpften oder ungeimpften zu reden
dass die einen guten oder die anderen
die schlechten Bürger sein da reicht es
auch nicht zu sagen dass es doch klug
wäre wenn ein Mensch mit einer Diabetes
sich doch besser impfen lassen wollte
denn wenn es lediglich um den
medizinischen Eigenschutz geht reicht
das nicht aus das wäre Paternalismus das
wird man im Lande Immanuel Kants noch
sagen dürfen
sondern worum es gehen muss ist der
Schutz des öffentlichen
Gesundheitssystems die Verteidigung der
Intensivstation und auch der
Normalstation vor Überlastung und darum
muss es gehen
und deshalb müssen wir uns die Frage
stellen und zwar ernsthaft ist das auch
mit milderen Mitteln möglich und deshalb
ist meine Bitte dass wir uns zwei Fragen
wirklich sehr ernsthaft vornehmen wenn
der Expertenrat der corona-expertenrat
sagt dass insbesondere die Gruppe der
über 50-Jährigen ungeimpften die größte
Sorge bereitet bei der Frage einer
künftigen Überlastung der
Intensivstation müssen wir die mildere
alternative einer altersbezogen einer
gestuften Impfpflicht sehr ernst nehmen
aber auch die Anhänger dieser gestuften
Impfpflicht müssen sich ernsthaft die
Frage stellen ist es nicht denkbar dass
wir mit den sehr vielversprechenden
antiviralen Medikamenten
die in den Studien eine extrem hohe
Wirksamkeit zeigen wenn wir die schnell
und flächendeckend zur Verfügung stellen
ist nicht möglicherweise auch das eine
Perspektive und ein Beitrag um unsere
Intensivstation und unsere Krankenhäuser
vor Überlastung zu schützen ich traue
mir heute da noch keine abschließende
Meinung zu aber wir müssen diese
milderen Alternativen nach besten Wissen
und Gewissen prüfen und darum möchte ich
bitten in dieser Debatte herzlichen Dank
meine Damen und Herren
das war Marco Buschmann von der FDP er
spricht sich dafür aus eine gestufte
Impfpflicht erst ab 50 oder mildere
Alternativen die ersten überprüfen
gerade für die FDP ist ja die allgemeine
Impfpflicht ein schwieriges Thema es
folgt Katrin Vogler von den Linken
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen seit zwei Jahren leiden die
Menschen in diesem Land unter der
corona-pandemie und auch unter den
Maßnahmen die ergriffen werden müssen um
dafür zu sorgen dass erkrankte schwer
erkrankte noch in den Krankenhäusern
behandelt werden können
diese Maßnahmen ob kontaktbeschränkungen
3G 2G oder quarantäneanordnung greifen
tief in die persönliche Freiheit ein und
angesichts der hoch ansteckenden
omikronvariante befürchten wir jetzt
sogar dass beispielsweise die Versorgung
mit Strom und Wasser zusammenbrechen
könnte das ist gemeint wenn wir
PolitikerInnen von kritischen
Infrastrukturen reden die Beschäftigten
in den Krankenhäusern die ja schon vor
der Pandemie am Limit waren riskieren
heute täglich Leben und Gesundheit um
Leid zu vermindern und Leben zu retten
und selbst wenn in unserem
Gesundheitswesen vor Corona alles in
Ordnung gewesen wäre selbst dann wäre
eine durchseuchungsstrategie vollkommen
unethisch denn der Staat ist
verpflichtet das Recht auf Leben und
körperliche Unversehrtheit aller
Menschen zu schützen auch der Kranken
der schwachen und der alten
was wir erleben in der Gesellschaft ist
eine zum Teil völlig verzerrte
Risikowahrnehmung die Gefahr durch Kurve
19 schwer zu erkranken dauerhafte
Gesundheitsschäden zu erleiden oder
sogar zu sterben wird massiv
unterschätzt stattdessen fürchten sich
noch viel zu viele vor den sehr sicheren
und inzwischen milliardenfach erprobten
Impfstoffen die einen schweren Verlauf
mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit verhindern
können und das kann ich ihnen von der
cdu/csu und von der SPD leider nicht
ersparen auch ihre Politik der letzten
zwei Jahre hat zu dieser Verunsicherung
beigetragen immer wieder haben sie Dinge
versprochen die sich dann in der
Realität nicht halten ließ
und immer wieder haben sie Warnungen aus
der Wissenschaft und aus anderen und
Erfahrungen aus anderen Ländern
ignoriert und mussten hinterher
nachsteuern eine vorausschauende Politik
war das nie und das merken wir zum
Beispiel auch an den immer noch
fehlenden Luftfiltern in Schulen und an
den viel zu wenigen testkapazitäten und
bis heute
bis heute hat es die Bundesregierung
nicht geschafft die Bevölkerung über den
Nutzen der Impfungen so aufzuklären dass
die corona-leugner die das Internet mit
Desinformation Fluten gegen eine Wand
der Solidarität laufen ja der
Solidarität das ist ein viel
missbrauchtes Wort aber ohne Solidarität
werden wir den Weg aus dieser Krise
nicht finden
eine Impfpflicht die ein Eingriff in die
körperliche selbstbestimmung ist kann da
immer nur ultima ratio sein also eine
letzte Möglichkeit wenn anders der
Schutz der Gesundheit und die
Wiedererlangung der Freiheiten nicht
erreicht werden können
aber dann davon bin ich überzeugt kann
eine Impfpflicht nicht nur
verfassungsgemäß sondern unter Umständen
sogar zwingend geboten sein um andere
hohe Rechtsgüter zu schützen das Recht
auf Leben und körperliche unversehrt hat
die persönlichen Freiheiten und die
Funktionsfähigkeit von
Bildungseinrichtungen Gesundheitswesen
und öffentlicher Daseinsvorsorge und das
müssen wir wirklich sehr sorgsam
besprechen also ich sehe da noch nicht
dass wir da am Ende der Diskussion sind
die Voraussetzung wäre es aber auch den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern eine
solche Pflicht so leicht wie möglich zu
machen und da brauchen wir
niedrigschwellige impfangebote aktive
Einladung verständliche
zielgruppengerechte Informationen wie
das Unsere Gesundheitssenatorin in
Bremen wirklich vorbildlich gemacht hat
und
sie entbindet die Politik nicht von der
Verantwortung unser Gesundheitswesen so
zu gestalten dass die dort arbeitenden
nicht täglich über Limit gehen müssen
vor während oder nach einer Pandemie und
Herr Scholz und Herr Lauterbach da
müssen sie liefern
das war Katrin vorgler von den Linken
sie wirft Union und SPD Versagen in der
corona-politik vor es fehle immer noch
zu viel wie zum Beispiel Luftfilter oder
Test zu schlecht sein alle informiert
worden nächste Rednerin und Heike
Behrens von der SPD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt nur
einen einzigen Gegner in dieser Pandemie
und das ist das Virus ich bin froh dass
die allermeisten in diesem Haus und in
unserem Land sich darin einig sind und
ich bin froh dass wir jetzt diese
intensive Debatte über den richtigen Weg
führen wie wir die Pandemie endlich
überwinden können in den letzten Jahren
haben wir uns sehr bemüht jeweils
situationsangepasst und maßvoll zu
reagieren wir sind dabei zumeist mit
weniger harten Einschränkungen als in
den allermeisten Ländern ausgekommen und
trotzdem sind viele Maßnahmen auch bei
uns mit erheblichen Belastungen
Folgeschäden und Problemen verbunden mir
geht es heute darum dafür zu werben dass
wir angesichts einer ungewissen Ankunft
konsequent für einen Weg der bewussten
Vorsorge uns entscheiden
aber wie kann Vorsorge gelingen in einer
Zeit in der sich der Wissensstand von
Tag zu Tag erweitert und wir regelmäßig
hinzulernen bei aller Unsicherheit und
Ungenauigkeit der Vorhersage haben wir
immerhin die Gewissheit das Impfen
schützt aber wir haben eben auch gelernt
allein auf die Hoffnung zu setzen dass
die aktuelle Welle die letzte sein Wort
ist keine gute Option erinnern wir uns
an den ersten pandemie-herbst erinnern
wir uns an den zweiten immer wieder
waren wir ausreichend nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet immer wieder wurde Politik
das Versäumnis guter Vorsorge
vorgeworfen und einen dritten
unkontrollierten pandemie-herbst darf es
nicht geben
weil die Zeit läuft und das Virus keine
Rücksicht nimmt auf Unentschlossenheit
Skepsis oder gar trotz
darum plädiere ich heute für die
Einführung einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht
für alle Erwachsenen beschränkt auf das
sarskow zwei Virus zeitlich befristet
und auf drei Impfdosen begrenzt mit
freier impfstoffwahl und
selbstverständlich muss es medizinische
Ausnahmen geben
ja wir hoffen alle darauf dass wir nach
der unicronwelle rasch zurückkehrenden
einen unbeschwerten Alltag ohne
freiheitseinschränkungen aber kein
Experte kann uns heute sagen dass die
Pandemie mit Omicron weitgehend
überstanden sein wird keiner gibt uns
die Sicherheit nicht von weiteren
Virusvarianten überrascht zu werden
diese Ungewissheit darf aber eben nicht
zutatenlosigkeit führen wir können
vorsorgen und damit vor die nächste
Welle kommen dafür braucht es jetzt eine
mutige Weichenstellung und die wollen
wir vornehmen
von Politik wird in dieser Zeit zu Recht
Orientierung erwartet und diese müssen
wir mit klaren Botschaften geben wir
werden die Lasten der Pandemie Folgen
gerechter verteilen und dürfen nicht
weiter die immer gleichen belasten das
sind vor allem die Kinder und
Jugendlichen die selbst am wenigsten
gefährdet und dennoch am meisten
eingeschränkt waren und es sind die
Beschäftigten in der Pflege die für uns
unverzichtbare Arbeit leisten und seit
Beginn der Pandemie besonderer
Gefährdung und Belastung ausgesetzt sind
und die sich jetzt durch die notwendige
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht noch
mehr als ewige und alleinige
Lastenträger fühlen eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ab 18 sendet die klare
Botschaft wir alle stehen in der
Verantwortung füreinander gesunde für
kranke Erwachsene für Kinder junge für
alte wir alle gemeinsam stehen in der
Verantwortung für die die in unseren
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
ungemein belastet sind
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam den Gegner
bezwingen der uns alle der unser aller
Gesundheit bedroht lassen sie uns dem
Virus geschlossen die Stirn bieten
stimmen Sie für die allgemeine
Impfpflicht vielen Dank
das war ein leidenschaftliches Plädoyer
für die befristete Impfpflicht Heike
Behrens von der SPD sie fordert dies als
Zeichen einer gerechteren
Lastenverteilung es folgt Andrea
Lindholz von der CDU Andrea Lindholz aus
der cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser Land
befindet sich mitten in einer
schwierigen Phase der Pandemie die Zahl
der Neuinfektionen überschreitet Tag für
Tag neue Höchstwerte die Bundesregierung
zögert und handelt nicht ganz klar ist
impfen ist ein zentraler Baustein auf
dem Weg aus der Pandemie und die
Steigerung der Impfquote muss unser
aller Ziel sein und ich bitte deshalb
auch jeden und jede helfen Sie mit
lassen sie sich impfen und ich danke
auch allen die sich schon geimpft haben
noch viel lieber
hätte ich heute nicht nur diesen Appell
an Sie gerichtet sondern auch über einen
fundierten Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung debattiert aber anstelle
eines regierungsentwurfes
sind verschiedene Anträge von
Abgeordneten der ampelfraktion mit
unterschiedlichen Herangehensweisen
angekündigt das führt zu
Verunsicherungen bei den Menschen im
Land und es zeichnet auch ein Bild von
Planlosigkeit und gerade das
ist bei einem so wichtigen Thema der
saströs die Regierung verweigert die
Arbeit sie legt keinen eigenen Entwurf
vor bei dem Pflegeberufen war das kein
Problem da gab es ein Gesetzesentwurf
und es war keine reine Gewissensfrage
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Ampel
ist in der Frage der Impfpflicht
führungs- und orientierungslos
und natürlich sind bei der Debatte über
die impfpflichtschwierige Fragen zu
beantworten wir als Unionsfraktion haben
deshalb schon vor vier Wochen mehr als
20 konkrete Fragen an die Regierung
gestellt Fragen zur Einordnung der
omegonvariante zum pandemie-management
zur Frage eines impfregisters die
Antwort kam gestern sie kam zu spät und
sie kam erst auf massiven Druck aber sie
lässt auch an vielen Stellen zu wünschen
übrig auf viele Fragen gibt es schlicht
gar keine Antwort man verweist auf
öffentlich zugängliche Quellen und nimmt
nicht mehr ansatzweise eine eigene
Einordnung vor keine Positionierung zum
Thema Impfpflicht keine Antwort auf die
Frage von Vollzug und Kontrolle keine
Antwort auf die Frage eines
impfregisters das sind nur einige
Beispiele stattdessen verweist man auf
das Parlament und die gruppenanträge und
die angekündigte Hilfestellung für das
Parlament die können wir hier nicht
sehen was wir aber erleben das ist
Arbeitsverweigerung der Bundesregierung
und eine Missachtung der Opposition
und für uns ist ganz klar die
Bundesregierung ist nach wie vor in der
Pflicht ein praktikablen und
verfassungskonform Vorschlag vorzulegen
der zentrale Fragen beantwortet und die
Expertise der Ministerien einbringt
wie bewerten aber wir diese ernste Lage
eine allgemeine Impfpflicht hilft uns
kurzfristig in der aktuell dramatischen
Situation nicht weiter dafür liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel ist
viel zu viel Zeit ungenutzt verstrichen
aktuell bräuchte es vor allem mehr
freiwillig Impfungen und es bräuchte
eine erfolgreiche Impfkampagne aber die
Impfkampagne für die Buße und
erstimpfungen stockt das von
Bundeskanzler Scholz ausgegebene Ziel
von 80 Prozent erstimpfungen bis Ende
Januar wird leider ganz klar verfehlt
die Quote bei den boosterimpfungen
stagniert bei 50 Prozent und auch das
ausgegebene Ziel zwischen Weihnachten
und Ende Januar 30 Millionen Impfungen
zu schaffen wird ganz klar nicht
erreicht wir liegen stand heute bei
knapp 15 Millionen Impfungen
das ist bedauerlich und das zeigt uns
eins der Bundesgesundheitsminister ist
mit seiner Impfkampagne hier ganz klar
gefordert
aus meiner Sicht steht aber auch fest
wir müssen uns für den Ernstfall
weiterer möglicherweise
gefährlicher Virusvarianten im Herbst
Wappen denn wir wünschen uns dass alle
nicht aber es kann eben auch niemand
ausschließen und eine vollständige oder
teilweise Impfpflicht sie kann die
Voraussetzung sein ab einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt sie kann notwendig sein um
eine Überforderung unseres
Gesundheitssystems zu verhindern und den
individualschutz zu erhöhen
das ist aber eine Frage von Daten Fakten
Fragen von Verhältnismäßigkeit und
Umsetzbarkeit und das ist eine Frage das
sind Fragen die hat die Regierung zu
beantworten und die Entscheidung darüber
die trifft das Parlament das ist eine
politische Entscheidung
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen fest
steht auch ganz klar wir brauchen ein
impfregister Fachleute aus dem
medizinischen aus dem ethischen und aus
dem rechtlichen Bereich sie raten
dringend dazu für diese Krise aber auch
für künftige pandemie-krisen ein solches
Register einzurichten denn es wäre mehr
als hilfreich wenn eine zuverlässige und
sichere Datengrundlage über den
Impfstatus unserer Bevölkerung Auskunft
gibt ein Register kann uns helfen bei
der Ansprache und Informationen es kann
bei der Datenerhebung und Auswertung
helfen diese zu verbessern es kann
Vorhersagen über die zu erwartende
Belastung unseres Gesundheitssystems
treffen und damit auch eine bessere
Bewertung von nötigen oder nicht nötigen
Maßnahmen ermöglichen denn am Ende ist
eins klar eine bessere Datengrundlage
das ist das was man braucht es ist nicht
ein mehr anbel sondern es schützt gerade
auch unser aller Freiheitsrechte und
deshalb fordern wir die Bundesregierung
auch auf die Einrichtung eines
allgemeinen impfregisters unverzüglich
auf den Weg zu bringen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren in der
Regierung ich kann es ihnen nicht
ersparen packen sie endlich an wir
brauchen Klartext und Klarheit bei
Impfkampagne Impfpflicht und
impfregister und es gibt verdammt viel
zu tun dankeschön
erneut kritisiert die CDU dass die
ampelregierung keinen Gesetzentwurf
bisher vorgelegt habe für Andrea
Lindholz ist das Arbeitsverweigerung und
eine Missachtung der Opposition nächste
Rednerin nun Paula pichota von den
Grünen sie ist übrigens auch Medizinerin
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und ich begrüße sie zu ihrer ersten rede
hier im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Damen und Herren sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und vor allen Dingen auch
liebe Frau Lindholz ich möchte sie nicht
auffordern ich möchte sie einfach als
Ärztin bitten daran zu denken das System
und Debatten in diesem Haus gibt die
wichtiger sind als parteipolitische
Profilierung darum bitte ich Sie und es
tut mir auch leid dass ich damit jetzt
hier so anfangen muss
das Spannende an dieser Debatte ist doch
egal wer von uns die in den letzten
Wochen geführt hat in diesem Haus und
außerhalb dieses Hauses es geht fast
niemand in diese Debatte ohne seinen
ganz persönlichen Rucksack an Emotionen
an Perspektiven auch an Dingen die in
persönlich wundgescheuert haben in den
letzten 24 Monaten in dieser Debatte und
das anzuerkennen dass vor allen Dingen
auch diese verschiedenen Perspektiven
mit darüber entscheiden werden was am
Ende hier mehrheitsfähig ist das gehört
doch an der Stelle zu einer ehrlichen
Debatte dazu und wenn wir uns da
anschauen
und wenn wir uns da anschauen wie
unterschiedlich diese Perspektiven sind
heute wird zum Beispiel Herr Kubicki
hier gleich noch reden wo ich gerade das
Vergnügen hatte neben ihm zu sitzen das
ist eine ganz andere Perspektive als
meine aus Schleswig-Holstein mit dieser
vergleichsweise guten Impfquote im
Bundesland was immer ziemlich gut durch
die Pandemie gekommen ist da verstehe
ich dass man zu der Überzeugung kommen
kann dass es keine Impfpflicht braucht
aber dann muss man sich auch die andere
Perspektive anhören und die kommt in
meiner Person aus Sachsen sie wissen
dass unser Bundesland hat die mit
Abstand schlechteste Impfquote wir sind
mit unseren knapp über 60 Prozent sind
wir näher an der tschechischen Impfquote
als am bundesdeutschen Durchschnitt wir
haben die meisten pro kopftoten kurz vor
sachsen-anhaltung Thüringen und vor
allen Dingen ist es auch so dass er
diese niedrige Impfquote auch dazu
geführt hat dass wir in den letzten
Monaten besonders langwierige und
besonders tiefgreifende Maßnahmen auch
noch mal bei uns hatten und das muss mit
berücksichtigt werden ich will nicht
dass wir am Ende eine Debatte haben wie
berücksichtigen wir vor allem die
Bundesländer die gerade die schlechteste
Impfquote haben aber wir brauchen am
Ende dieses Prozess ist eine Regelung
die für alle Bundesländer funktioniert
und hier sind schon Punkte angesprochen
worden
die vor allen Dingen auch die
Umsetzbarkeit betreffen und ich möchte
einfach darauf hinweisen dass es einen
großen Unterschied macht auch wie
praktikabelnde Regelung ist ob ich in
dem Bundesland noch 40 Prozent
ungeimpfte habe oder nur 20 Prozent ich
spreche heute als eine Vertreterin von
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen in diesem
Haus die vorschlagen einen sogenannten
Mittelweg zu gehen obwohl ich mit dem
Begriff nicht ganz ganz glücklich bin
und dieser Mittelweg heißt wir machen
eine Verpflichtung zur Impfung ab 50 für
die besonders gefährdeten Gruppen wir
machen aber auch eine verpflichtende
Impfberatung ab 18 und es fällt mir
natürlich auch nicht leicht dazu sagen
dass es der beste Weg durch diese Krise
und aus dieser Krise ist
aber es ist auf jeden Fall so dass wir
hier versuchen die gesellschaftlichen
Nebenwirkungen die dieses Medikament
Impfpflicht auch haben kann mitzudenken
und die zu minimieren niemand kann Ihnen
sagen und das kann ich jetzt nur noch
anreißen niemand kann Ihnen sagen ob wir
tatsächlich diesen befriedenen Effekt in
allen Bundesländern haben werden oder ob
es nicht auch radikalisierungstendenzen
geben wird und erreicht auch kein Glaube
als Mensch der in Sachsen lebt kann ich
da nicht drauf vertrauen dass es einfach
Befriedung geben wird da muss ich mit
einpreisen dass es auch anders sein kann
und deswegen werde ich für diesen
anderen Weg und ich freue mich auf die
nächsten Wochen mit ihnen weil das
Schöne an dieser Debatte ist am Ende ja
auch das ist fast alle von uns eint dass
wir diese Zumutung diese demokratische
und gesundheitliche und soziale Zumutung
die diese Pandemie ist dass wir die
endlich hinter uns bringen und wir
tragen fast alle in diesem Haus
Verantwortung egal ob hier oder in den
Ländern und deswegen freue ich mich auf
die Zusammenarbeit mit Ihnen vielen Dank
das war Paula pichota von Bündnis 90
grüne sie spricht sich für eine
Impfpflicht für über 50-Jährige sowie
eine Impfberatung für jüngere aus es
folgt nun Alice Weide
Fraktionsvorsitzende der AFD die
Abgeordnete Doktor Alice Weidel aus der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Werte
Damen und Herren unser Land steht an der
Schwelle eines beispiellosen Sündenfalls
die Absicht eine allgemeine Impfpflicht
gegen das Coronavirus einzuführen ist
ein Anschlag auf die Freiheit und
Menschenwürde und auf Grundrecht auf die
körperliche Unversehrtheit
die Impfpflicht ist ein autoritärer
Amoklauf gegen die Grundfesten unserer
demokratischen und rechtsstaatlichen
Grundordnung wenn der Staat sich anmaß
über die Körper seiner Bürger zu
entscheiden ist das ein elementarer
Zivilisationsbruch
es ist ein Trauerspiel das wir überhaupt
darüber reden müssen für eine
corona-impfpflicht egal ob für alle oder
für einzelne Bevölkerungsgruppen gibt es
keine Rechtfertigung weder medizinisch
noch ethisch noch juristisch eine
Impfpflicht gegen eine Krankheit die für
mehr als 99 Prozent der Menschen keine
lebensgefährliche Bedrohung darstellt
mit einem Impfstoff der weder vor
Ansteckung noch vor der Weitergabe des
Erregers zuverlässig schützt ist absurd
Menschen zu einer Impfung zu nötigen und
zu zwingen ist deshalb eine unerhörte
Grenzüberschreitung die Impfpflicht ist
verfassungswidrig und unverhältnismäßig
es gibt andere
es gibt andere vernünftige und
zielführende Wege um die
Gesundheitsversorgung aufrecht zu
erhalten zum Beispiel indem die
Gesundheitsminister ihren Job machen im
Bund und in den Ländern
für anständige Arbeitsbedingungen sorgen
ordentliche Bezahlung und mehr Personal
in den Kliniken die Impfpflicht ist auch
nicht durchführbar davor waren die
Kassenärzte da verwarnt der Beamtenbund
da verwarnt der Arbeitgeberverband
Gesamtmetall wie wollen sie eigentlich
Millionen von Bürger die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen zu einer Impfung
zwingen mit Bußgeldern und
Erzwingungshaft wie stellen Sie sich das
vor
und darum unser Rat an sie hören Sie
also nicht nur auf die Pharma-Lobbyisten
sondern hören Sie auf die Praktika in
diesem Land
aber sie wissen ja eben auch dass die
Impfpflicht der Impfzwang falsch ist vor
der Wahl haben sie selbst noch ganz
anders geredet herr Scholz und Herr
Lindner die Impfpflicht ist nicht
zuletzt vor allem eins ein gigantischer
Wählerbetrug ein skandalöser
Vertrauensbruch darüber reden wir
sie klammern sich an die Impfpflicht
weil sie sich komplett verrannt haben
verrannt in eine Politik der
Bevormundung und Entrechtung zwei Jahre
regide corona-politik gebaut auf
falschen Zahlen manipulierten
Statistiken widersprüchlichen Behauptung
haben ihre Glaubwürdigkeit gründlich
ramponiert sie haben das Land mit
lebenden Regelwerken und einer
kafkaisten
corona-bürokratie überzogen die die
Bürger in die Verzweiflung treiben ihr
Versuch einen defacto Impfzwang über
sinnlose und willkürliche 2G und
3g-regeln einzuführen hat die
Gesellschaft bereits tief gespalten vor
allem Kinder und Jugendliche leiden
unter der Zerstörung ihres sozialen
Umfelds
denn diese Regelwerke ihnen aufzwingen
diese Quälerei muss ein Ende haben sie
haben eine Behörde das
Robert-Koch-Institut dazu ermächtigt mit
einseitigen Änderungen dieser Regel
Millionen Menschen über Nacht und nach
Belieben in ihren Rechten weiter zu
beschneiden das ausgerechnet im
Bundestag
willkürentscheidung wie die
Einschränkung des genesenen Status nur
abgeschwächt gelten sollen empfinden die
Bürger zurecht als Hohn
alle Menschen sind gleich manche
gleicher damit haben sie im übrigen
völlig unbeabsichtigt offenbart was sie
wirklich von den Menschen da draußen
halten und bereits jetzt ist abzusehen
dass die von ihnen durchgedrückte
Impfpflicht für die Medizin und
Pflegebereich
Existenzen ruiniert
engagierte Fachkräfte mit Berufsverbot
belegt und die Krise in diesem Sektor
noch verschärft kommen Sie also heraus
aus ihrer Bunkermentalität machen Sie
das Fenster auf schauen Sie nach Europa
was hier passiert in England fallen nach
und nach alle corona-restriktionen nicht
trotz sondern wegen ormikron das gleiche
in Dänemark in Spanien will man das
Virus künftig nur noch wie eine normale
Grippe behandeln
in Tschechien wird die geplante
Impfpflicht für ältere und bestimmte
Berufsgruppen wieder einkassiert sie hat
sich nämlich als Flop erwiesen und hören
Sie auf die Bürger zu verunglimpfen den
dieser großen Protestbewegungen in der
Geschichte unseres Landes ihre Stimme
äußern nehmen Sie diese Stimmen ernst
und schaffen sie endlich diese
unsinnigen und diskriminierenden Regeln
ab und zwar vollständig und überall
ersparen Sie uns die zum Scheitern
verurteilte Impfpflicht für
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeeinrichtungen
kippen Sie sie bevor es zu spät ist
darum bitten wir Sie wir müssen mit dem
Virus Leben
Freiheit und Eigenverantwortung sind der
Schlüssel jeder muss für sich frei
entscheiden können ob er sich durch eine
Impfung und auf eine andere Art und
Weise schützen möchte darum lassen sie
um Gottes Willen die Hände von der
Impfpflicht ich bedanke mich
das war Alice Weidel von der AFD sie
hält eine Impfpflicht für absurd und
verfassungswidrig fordert stattdessen
eine bessere Ausstattung des
Gesundheitswesens nächster Redner nun
Wolfgang Kubicki von der FDP er hat sich
ganz klar gegen die Impfpflicht
ausgesprochen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zunächst einmal möchte ich mich
bei meiner eigenen Fraktion und vielen
Kollegen Kollegen aus dem Haus bedanken
dafür dass wir trotz unterschiedlicher
Auffassung im Ergebnis eine sehr
respektvolle und sehr faire Debatte
haben führen können denn wir alle wissen
dass wir eigentlich nichts wissen
trotzdem unsere Bewertung vornehmen
müssen anhand der Datenlage die wir
haben und die kann naturgemäß
unterschiedlich ausfallen
und da ich
die Beitritt des Kollegen Sorge sehr
aufmerksam zugehört hat ist mir klar
geworden dass die orientierungsdebatte
wirklich einen Sinn hat denn die Union
sucht ja noch eine Orientierung und wir
sind dabei Ihnen dabei zu helfen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meinen
persönlichen meine persönlichen Freemail
days waren die Tage meiner
corona-impfungen ich habe mich bewusst
für die Impfung und fürs Boostern
entschieden weil ich der festen
Überzeugung war und bin dass es mich mit
großer Wahrscheinlichkeit vor einem
schweren Krankheitsverlauf und vor dem
Tod durch Corona bewahrt es war für mich
persönlich ein enorm befreiendes Gefühl
es ist ein großes Geschenk dass dieser
Impfstoff innerhalb so kurzer Zeit
entwickelt wurde und dass ich mich
außerdem frei entscheiden konnte diesen
Schritt zu gehen ich bin froh und
dankbar in einem Gemeinwesen leben zu
können in dem das möglich ist
reden wir heute über die Impfpflicht
müssen wir gleichzeitig darüber sprechen
wie der Staat diejenigen gegenübertritt
die sich bisher gegen eine Impfung
entschieden haben ich erinnere
ausdrücklich daran dass es noch nicht
allzu lange her ist das ist der
ausdrückliche Wille der überwältigen
Mehrheit dieses Hauses war den Bürgern
und Bürgern selbst die Freiheit zu
Entscheidung zu überlassen der Gedanke
war grundlegend dass der staatliche
Eingriff auf einen bestimmten Zeitpunkt
enden muss wenn alle ein impfangebot
erhalten haben und dann jeder das
individuelle Lebensrisiko wieder selbst
trägt
setzt die Mehrheit des Hohen Hauses nun
aber trotz aller Betäubungen zuvor die
allgemeine Impfpflicht um hat das
Auswirkungen auf das Menschenbild dass
dieses Gemeinwesen aussendet so mag der
Tag der Impfung für all jene die sich
freiwillig hier zu entscheiden der
Freedom Day gewesen sein ja aber werden
diejenigen den Tag nennen an dem sie
gegen ihren erklärten Willen geimpft
wurden
die Kollegen ist es häufig zu hören dass
eine Impfung vernünftig ist und deshalb
die staatliche Verpflichtung ein Gebot
der gesellschaftlichen Notwendigkeit sei
ich teile ausdrücklich die Auffassung
dass eine Impfung vernünftig ist
trotzdem halte ich die Idee der
staatliche für alle Bürgerinnen und
Bürger fest was vernünftig ist zumindest
für problematisch
die individuellen Gründe jene Wellen
Gründe sich nicht impfen zu lassen
können vielfältig sein wir machen es uns
viel zu einfach wenn wir erklären
hauptsächlich corona-leugner und
rechtsradikale entschieden sich gegen
die Impfung das ist mitnichten so wir
müssen respektieren das ist durchaus
bedenkenswerte psychologische oder
religiöse Gründe gibt eine Impfung für
sich persönlich abzulehnen wer wehren
wir wenn wir diese Gründe im Sinne des
allgemeinschutzes als nicht zulässig
erachten würden insbesondere dass wir
mittlerweile wissen dass der fremdschutz
durch eine Impfung kaum mehr gegeben ist
auch deshalb fällt es mir schwer bei der
Impfung von einem Akt der Solidarität zu
sprechen wie es viele tun weil Impfung
keine sterile Immunität liefert dient
sie zuallererst dem Selbstschutz wir tun
gut daran die Impfung nicht durch eine
moralische Aufladung sondern
solidaritätspflicht zu machen denn damit
würden wir sie zwangsläufig politisieren
und Menschen die persönliche Gründe
gegen eine Impfung anführen können
stigmatisieren und zu Karies der
Gesellschaft machen
Kollegen im Kern geht es heute deshalb
auf um den Minderheitenschutz der durch
eine Impfpflicht berührt wird ich möchte
jedenfalls nicht dass die Mehrheit für
die Minderheit festlegt was man als
vernünftig anzusehen hat und was man
nach mehrheitsmanukt tun muss um
solidarisch zu sein denn wenn die
Minderheit von der Mehrheit in
grundrechtssensiblen Fragen und der
Rückgriff auf eine höheren Moral einfach
überstimmt wird dann können wir nur
hoffen dass wir in die Verlegenheit
kommen werden Teil einer Minderheit zu
sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt
gute Gründe für die Impfung die für eine
Impfpflicht überzeugen mich nicht weder
droht ein Kollaps das Gesundheitssystems
bei massiv steigender Infektionszahlen
sinken die Behandlungszahlen auf den
Intensivstationen noch kann eine
Impfpflicht noch etwas zu Bewältigung
der omegonwelle beitragen ein massiven
Grundrechtseingriff mit einer möglichen
Mutante im Herbst zu begründen die wir
noch nicht kennen und an den Impfstoff
die wir noch nicht haben sozusagen eine
Impfpflicht auf Vorrat halte ich auch
aus rechtlicher Sicht für nichtvertreter
vielen Dank
das war kurz und knapp Wolfgang Kubicki
er hält eine Impfung für vernünftig will
es sich aber nicht vom Staat
vorschreiben lassen eine Impfung auf
Vorrat schon gar nicht es gäbe triftige
Gründe sich nicht impfen zu lassen
nächster Redner nun Mathias birkwald von
den Linken
übrigens auch auch für sie gilt das
Zeichen Präsident wenn das aufläuft
[Applaus]
nächster Redner ist der Abgeordnete
Matthias W birkwald aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit 25 Jahren
lasse ich mich jedes Jahr gegen Grippe
impfen ich habe nahezu alle von der
Ständigen Impfkommission empfohlenen
Impfung erhalten das sind weit über 20
und ich bin selbstverständlich
vollständig geimpft und ich habe mich
bewusst Boostern lassen obwohl ich seit
sieben Monaten Schmerzen an der
Einstichstelle nach der zweiten Impfung
verspüre und obwohl mein Vater
einen Tag nach seiner Impfung gegen
kovid 19 verstorben ist was offiziell
keinen Zusammenhang mit der Impfung
hatte sich aber nach wie vor völlig
anders anfühlt ich habe also eine
individuelle Risikoabwägung vorgenommen
und mich im Anschluss für die Impfung
entschieden ich halte diese freie
Entscheidung für den richtigen Weg für
alle erwachsenen Menschen in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
eine Entscheidung für oder gegen eine
Impfung gegen Kurve 19 sollte immer
selbstbestimmt und individuell nach der
Aufklärung über persönliche Chancen und
Risiken getroffen werden können ich
werbe dafür die individuellen
demokratischen Grundrechte der freien
Persönlichkeitsentfaltung und der
körperlichen Unversehrtheit der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
demokratischen und sozialen
Rechtsstaates keinesfalls durch eine
Impfpflicht gegen kovit 19
einzuschränken
ich werbe für einen rationalen und einen
humanistischen Umgang mit der
corona-pandemie und ich bin nicht in
jedem Fall gegen eine Impfpflicht bei
der sinnvollen masernimpfpflicht habe
ich mich enthalten weil Verstöße gegen
die Impfpflicht mit 2.500 Euro
sanktioniert werden diese Summe müssen
investmentbankerinnen genauso zahlen wie
Hartz IV Betroffene und als Linker sage
ich das ist zutiefst sozial ungerecht
wir linken stehen für die soziale
Teilhabe aller Menschen wenn das Bußgeld
aber beispielsweise wieder 2.500 Euro
betrüge dann könnten sich die
Wohlhabenden von der impfpflichtfrei
kaufen aber Paketboten Kassiererinnen
Reinigungskräfte und Kellner könnten
dies nicht tun nach gegenwärtigem recht
drohte ihnen sogar nach mehrfacher
Weigerung Bußgelder zu zahlen eine
Erzwingungshaft im Gefängnis liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dazu darf es
auf gar keinen Fall kommen
es geht auch Unglaubwürdigkeit
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hatte seinerzeit
eine allgemeine impfpflichtkategorisch
ausgeschlossen im Januar 2021 konnte man
auf der Internetseite des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums lesen nein
es wird keine allgemeine Impfpflicht
geben Zitat Ende ich stehe für eine
glaubwürdige Politik ich habe dies
meinen Wählerinnen und Wählern in Köln
vor der Wahl versprochen und werde mich
jetzt auch nach der Wahl daran bei
meinem
Abstimmungsverhalten erinnern ich komme
zum Schluss liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
bitte tun Sie dies auch denn hier geht
es um Vertrauensschutz aktuell heißt es
ja es werde keinen Impfzwang geben wer
soll denn das noch glauben wenn die
Aussage eine Impfpflicht sei
ausgeschlossen schon nach so kurzer Zeit
nicht mehr das Papier wert ist auf dem
sie gedruckt wurde nein diese
Impfpflicht ist eine autoritäre Illusion
besser als diese Impfpflicht wäre es die
Menschen zu überzeugen ich danke Ihnen
das war Matthias birkwald von den Linken
er wirbt für einen rationalen Umgang mit
der Impfpflicht wenn sie denn überhaupt
kommen vor allem dann müsse es sozial
gerechte Bußgelder geben nächster Redner
nun Takis mehr mit Ali von der SPD
Ali aus der SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren bevor ich mit
der inhaltlichen Debatte anfangen möchte
ich doch eine Sache loswerden wer diese
Debatte heute verfolgt der wird
feststellen in was für eine lebhaften
Demokratie wir sind und dass wir in
solch eine Debatte in einer Diktatur gar
nicht führen würden das was nämlich
einige Verschwörungstheoretiker und
einige demokratiefeinde in diesem Land
behaupten meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte
ich möchte meine Aufmerksamkeit bei
meinen Redebeitrag den Einrichtungen der
Eingliederungshilfe und den und für die
Menschen mit Behinderung widmen wir
haben ungefähr vor eineinhalb Monaten
die Parzelle Impfpflicht eingeführt die
wird bestimmte Konsequenzen mit sich
bringen das spüren wir teilweise das
bringt das hört man auch in der in den
Diskussionen mit der freien
Wohlfahrtspflege auch ich möchte aber
auch darstellen dass nicht die Parzelle
Impfpflicht das Problem ist sondern dass
insbesondere in der Eingliederungshilfe
seit 30 40 Jahren nicht nachgegangenen
neuen Infrastrukturen das Problem sind
wir haben teilweise eine
Refinanzierungsstruktur in der
Behindertenhilfe gehabt die lässt sich
wirklich zu wünschen übrig ich habe ihn
mal sogar mal heute ein Rechenbeispiel
mitgebracht wie wir es in
Baden-Württemberg haben stellen Sie sich
mal vor einen 24er Wohnheim bei einem
Personalschlüssel von 1 zu 2,54 das
bedeutet
9,44 voll vorstellen und die
landespersonalverordnung in
Baden-Württemberg sagt davon darf nur 50
Prozent die Fachkräfte sein das bedeutet
dass ich 4,77 Fachkräfte habe und 4,77
Hilfskräfte und die darf ich dann auch
noch mal in drei Wohngruppen verteilen
bitte sehen Sie das nach meine Damen und
Herren wenn wirklich von diesen Menschen
ein zwei Personen dann die Einrichtung
verlassen dass das weh tut das tut den
Einrichtungen weh aber deshalb müssen
wir auch hingehen und sagen naja wo
wandert denn das Personal hin sie
wandern aktuell in die übrigen
Hilfestrukturen in die Jugendhilfe in
die Obdachlosenhilfe da wo sie eben
momentan eine arbeitsheimat finden
können erschweren kommt noch hinzu wenn
sie auch noch ein Wahlkreis haben wie
ich Lörrach Mülheim an der Schweizer
Grenze dass die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sagen naja da fahre ich halt mal zehn
Minuten rüber und schafft bislang der
Schweiz ja und das erschwert eben
zusätzlich die Situation in den
Einrichtungen aber wir können das
Problem lösen wir können das Problem
nämlich mit einer allgemeinen Pflicht
lösen weil dann muss sich jeder
verpflichten in diesem Land der in
diesen Hilfestrukturen auch arbeiten
möchte auch hier eben seinen Beitrag zu
leisten meine Damen und Herren
und was vielleicht zusätzlich auch noch
erschwerend auch noch dazu kommt ist der
übrige Umstand dass die Einrichtungen
und auch die Menschen mit Behinderung
selber oder Ihre Angehörigen auch Sorgen
darüber haben was passiert denn wenn die
Gesundheitsämter in den Einrichtungen
jetzt ihren Ermessensspielraum auch noch
ausüben wir haben in Baden-Württemberg
beispielsweise 44 statt und Landkreise
die dann zuständig sind dann macht er
eine Landkreis dass das Gesundheitsamt
dort und der andere Landkreis
entscheidet dann das das bringt
Unsicherheiten auch hier können wir
sagen wenn wir eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht haben werden wir auch die
Probleme der Patienten Impfpflicht
aufheben können und damit auch
Sicherheit schaffen bei den
Leistungserbringern bei den
Leistungsberechtigten und bei den
Leistungsträgern meine Damen und Herren
zumal zumal wir ja auch noch
gegebenenfalls auch auch eine Struktur
hin steuern dass ich selber
konkurrierendes Ordnungsrecht nenne wir
werden auf der einen Seite die
landesspezifischen Regelungen haben wie
beispielsweise die heimgesetze die dann
die Einrichtungen dazu verpflichten eben
Leistungsverpflichtung gegenüber den
Menschen mit Behinderung nachzukommen
aber wenn dann das Personal ausfällt
weil sie vielleicht auch krank werden
weil sie sich angesteckt haben wird es
dazu führen dass das andere Personal ja
mehr gefordert wird was passiert dann
wenn das Arbeitszeitgesetz nicht
eingehalten werden kann das heißt ich
habe auf der einen Seite das Heimgesetz
auf der anderen Seite das
Arbeitszeitgesetz zwei
ordnungsrechtliche Rahmenbedingungen die
miteinander konkurrieren die
Einrichtungen die Menschen mit
Behinderung wissen heute immer noch
nicht was dann die Konsequenz sein wird
und auch hier können wir sagen wenn die
Verantwortung für diese Menschen mit
Behinderung die in Einrichtungen leben
oder auch die alleine leben den Dienst
die Leistung der Dienste noch in
Anspruch nehmen können können wir sagen
wer die Verantwortung übernimmt der wird
auch hier für die Menschen mit
Behinderung auch weiterhin die Leistung
erbringen können
ach so ich die Zeit ist schon vorbei das
ist das ist schon länger vorbei das ist
das Zeichen davon sehr sehr ärgerlich
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich
appelliere auch an die Menschen die in
den Einrichtungen arbeiten lassen Sie
uns gemeinsam für die Menschen mit
Behinderung da sein ich hätte ihn ja
noch so viel Wichtiges erzählt aber das
mache ich dann noch ein andermal vielen
Dank fürs zuhören
so auch für uns ist die Zeit vorbei wir
blenden uns an dieser Stelle aus der
orientierungsdebatte aus über die
konkreten Anträge wird der Bundestag
erst später möglicherweise bis Ende März
abstimmen heute daher nur ein erstes
Meinungsbild das Thema Impfpflicht
bleibt uns erhalten für heute bedanke
ich mich für Ihr Interesse wer möchte
kann die Debatte weiter auf Phoenix
verfolgen ich wünsche noch einen schönen
Tag und sage Tschüss bis zum nächsten
Mal
[Musik]